said that they should no longer Pander
to political correctness what did you
mean
well I think uh whilst uh our police
officers are brave and uh excellent on
the whole I think there has been a
tendency for uh the public to grow weary
of uh some of the uh time-wasting uh
behavior that police have been engaged
in so I don't want the police to be
engaged in uh politically uh debates on
social media about gender I don't want
the police to shut be shying away from
tackling really important issues like
grooming gangs because of political
correctness I don't want the police to
be uh you know not I want the police to
be using their stop and search Powers
because that's an effective tool to
reduce violence and save lives and um in
in some instances we've seen political
correctness get in the way of Common
Sense policing